hello everybody and welcome to part 18
of let's play penumbra overture as you
all know I just got my victory flash got
my code one three seven one wait what
huh huh what was it look ah
tell me tell me what one three seven it
was one three seven one I know this oh
so smart I remember things but I'm going
the wrong way you didn't see that ah
right let's do this I'm ready I'm ready
to get out of here I'm ready
Oh section C oh yeah fence jump leap
awesome
alright oh I'm looking forward to some
monsters bing-bong bing-bong yeah I'm
the man I am the man victory flash all
right where am I
what do you got in store for me nothing
yeah no a bunch of wusses Oh a dog huh
I'm so bad so worried hahahaha hey hey
get out of here
oh man you push that crate far yeah
that's right run away I'm not having a
bother trying to kill you I know you
can't take me oh shut up shut up Billy
get away dog Billy oh yeah oh so I win I
win as in any drama there aren't many
roles to be placed uh-huh must act the
scientistic mixing potions act whatever
I want a gated lots of district oh shut
up
I act like a badass you may discover the
noise of my list
Oh
I don't look good hardware those things
oh boy hey oh ha ha
all right yeah bring it on Oh Oh Britt
are jumping are so easy
oh so skilled aah get out here aah that
shut up Billy
Oh get out of here Oh get out of here
I'll bring it on
Oh actually look at you this time oh
yeah I got a seal that oh whoa oh no oh
no no no no aah oh oh okay all right
got a seal the dip button man
my great jumping skills are not in
demand here oh oh yeah I got ya oh yeah
yeah yeah
aah hey hey stop it
Bank oh oh I get it haha as I said on
this is so trapped so smart
good I hear oh if I hold down the mouse
button helps get in there oh hey Oh
painkillers tuck suck it up John ah okay
there get in there get in there go there
and go there everything is coming in
yeah y'all get in there
mmm you son of a [ __ ] you're off you're
ruining me ah ah yeah yeah yeah oh yeah
ah no oh no oh no oh no not me oh all
right no more [ __ ] around you weren't
gonna get it I'm gonna get it go get it
Oh your butt yeah Oh Lee
ah so skilled Oh Oh door closed in
everything come on wacky wacky whack
there we go you two get out of here
there we go
all right you go in there you go all
right that's good enough of those
apparently I can make it all right good
enough okay I'm so strong oh yeah come
on come on
ah checky checky checky checky checky
checky checky checky hey Jay how do I
know it's open ah
not even a little bit what the [ __ ] ah
ah is it bad
oh I'm [ __ ] I am [ __ ] I'm just there
we go there we go
oh come on I hate this I hate so much
why did that suddenly work oh oh this is
the worst oh it's the worst okay all
right
I'm not messing around come on I'm up
oh yeah skills to pay the bills
yep yep yep yep okay okay you go in and
I go in and then I jump like a badass
and then I spin this super fast come on
come on come on
there we go come on little more come on
there we go oh yeah oh my god
oh my god oh I'm [ __ ] I am oh come on
oh I'm trying I'm trying
I'm doing this run there's something
wrong oh I get it I get it
I got it I got it I got it ah yeah ah
yeah I win I win I win oh and now you go
fast so close now for you to blow down
the walls oh no man Bob doesn't sell it
release me from this mortal coil oh I'm
sorry if I overloaded my mic there oh
man
that sucked that sucked
come on come on all you stupid wheel
there we go oh okay all right
oh man that sucked balls oh what's this
all right chemical very descriptive
Horst you are y'all still yep
uh-huh they're not very good copies no
one's gonna make a good copy of me I'm
so awesome can't be copied get out here
oh what's this a shoe yeah here i'm air
i'm air another chemical is it a more
different chemical or is it the same
chemical you don't even know do you
oh look that's a different chemical got
my chemicals come here come on open up
yeah it opened all flares yeah I should
probably use those at some point another
chemical D I think I saw yeah there we
got nothing oh yeah ah so smart looking
everywhere finding stuff yep I think
that was everything I think he was
everything all right oh yeah I'm the
best all right bring it on Oh dog I
screwed you I don't care how you doin
care anymore where am I
all right I went in that chemical
storage I think I came out that chemical
storage and that was fun lake otaku uh
I'm in the incinerator yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yep left left again all my
memories just unreal all yeah
oh here it is yep that's fantastic the
right tool there's a joke in there
somewhere but I'm not gonna make it
broom BAM come on
don't be like that
I'm putting that up there shut up moving
that over I'm gonna kill the next dog it
comes right with my broom what do we got
here
well that's going on all right let's
look at the map again Section B I go
Section B go a broom I don't need you
right now
ah come on why why why do you taunt me
why even make a level design with it in
it if you're never gonna use it why why
why ah hate this there was another
action to the entrance of Section B yep
okay right down here probably right by a
dog about I don't care I'm Way too
badass yeah yeah [ __ ] you
section B oh yeah of course it is Jim
let's show you Jim ugh room yes Mac
don't even try it
I can walk dog yeah blood from a broom
so badass
yeah yeah yeah get out of here oh oh
yeah you're just bleeding everywhere
come on bring it Oh Dustin the [ __ ] out
of you all right I'll be merciful yeah
oh poor time yep
Oh looks like that broom did do some
damage
yeah oh right fine I'll find my way
elsewhere time to go to Lake Utah keho
or Takaful oh yeah I can keep going
lick ooh kataka aah
open up get outta here oh go away dog I
don't care I don't even care I didn't
care anymore I'm so brave i don'ti don't
even mind oh we got here wow the way got
here yep yeah that's what I thought this
door better not be shut yet thank you
God
tired of shut doors okay
I'm gonna pause it here but I'm getting
right back into the action I'll see you
in part 19 of let's play penumbra
overture bye-bye